foreign
[Music]
for the previous game
it's time to start from the beginning
for Paradox to release the same game
again
yet evolve into something new
this city has a story of you spending
two hours looking for the one mod
breaking your save
and vision a World created by you
where induced demand apparently doesn't
exist
or parking space management despite
being the most fundamental aspects of
modern urban planning
your chance to shape the future and turn
poop into Infinite Power
create and inspire
municipally owned factories
expand way up high once the skyscraper
DLC comes out and bring life to your
Creations through mods that make the
game actually playable
new worlds to explore and pursue
where you get actively punished for
mixed zoning
[Music]
here
you are the Visionary
you are the Creator
you pay for downloadable content that
should have been included in the base
game